Thinking about Rick and Morty theories can get really daunting. Like remember the episode with the brain parasites that you could only identify
if you couldn't think of any bad memories of em? Well,
I don't have any bad memories of Rick and Morty... so does that mean the show is a parasite? Oh boy it's gettin' weird...
(Introduction Music)
Hello internet, welcome to Film Theory!! the squanchiest show in all of squanch
"Your language has the word squanch in it a lot." So with the new season of Rick and Morty starting July 30th,
I've been digging through everything I can find about the series and uh my mind is going to some really weird
places. Like you know how Rick created a microverse where the inhabitants had to perform the same repetitive tasks over and over again to generate
the electricity that Rick's spaceship runs on? Well
What if our world was created simply to power another, more intelligent civilization?
I mean you laugh, but consider this: In the show they had to step on Gooble boxes. In real life,
what repetitive tasks came out of nowhere and now has everyone mesmerised?
Fidget Spinners! But that's crazy, right?
It's not like we have any evidence that fidget spinners exist in Rick and Morty's universe, let alone that they were invented by Rick
except I mean, what's that on the jacket of literally every Rick on the council of Ricks?
(Explosions!!)
but hey, that's just a theory, a film theory! Annnnnd
Fade back up because episode isn't over yet. Putting aside
conspiracy theories about whether our fidgets spinner crazed society is just a teeny-verse powering a miniverse created by Rick today
I want to look ahead to the future of Rick and Morty to theorize about one of the show's most
fascinating and threatening characters, Eye-Patch Morty. Otherwise known as evil
Morty. If you need a refresher course, Evil Morty's only appearance is in the season 1 episode
"Close Rick-counters of the Rick Kind" wherein he and an evil rick
Assassinate a number of other Ricks across multiple dimensions and then try to frame the show's main Rick, Rick C-137 for the crime
Oh, yeah
by the way, fair warning don't, and I repeat do not play a drinking game where every time I say either Rick or
Morty during this episode you take a drink. I guarantee you'll be dead by minute five. Anyway, by the end of the episode
Evil Rick is killed and Evil Morty sneaks away uncaptured. Blending into a sea of freed Mortys.
But here's where it really gets interesting.
It's revealed at the end of the episode that Evil Rick was just a robot, and that it was Evil
Morty who was controlling him via a control in his eyepatch the whole time
CLEARLY that is a HUGE
Cliffhanger to end on, and based on what the creators are saying, Evil Morty probably won't be hiding out for very much longer
They've definitely been a little cagey, but just listen to how the creators of the series talk about this character
"We probably talked about Evil Morty in their writer's room more than we actually spent working on episodes that aired"
"When we want to come back to something really cool like like Evil Morty, I want to make sure I know what's his motivation,
What's his backstory, what's going on? And it has to be inspired"
So it's just not a question of IF Evil Morty comes back, it's WHEN
As for his motivations, well
What if I told you that Evil Morty was Rick's previous
Morty? you heard that right! The rickest of all Ricks, Szechuan lovin' Rick Sanchez
main title character Rick, that Morty with an eyepatch is his
Original Morty and that Evil Morty's revenge on Rick is likely to be a major factor in upcoming episodes
Oh boy, here I go a' theorizing again. Just call me Krombopulos MatPat. Now before you swiftiest
Rick and Morty fans get all bent out of shape and fold yourselves in half twelve times. I will say that
I'm not the first person to think that evil morty used to be paired up with Rick C-137
But while I've seen the theory,
I haven't really seen much evidence for it. That makes it much more of a
Hypothesis than a theory really, by the same token at this point enough has been said on the internet about Rick and Morty that I
Can't be sure that any theory about the show hasn't been thought up before
I mean there are some people online who believe that Morty's grandmother is Miss Frizzle from the Magic School Bus because uh
because Summer has red hair and Miss Frizzle also has red hair and likes science and heck even Arnold got the unique
experience of shoving Magic school buses way
Up his butt
anyway TLDR even if you think you've heard a theory like this before you'll want to stick around because this is the theoriest of
Theories when it comes to tracking the true story behind Evil Morty, and that's the wayyyyy
The news goes! Now you might say off the bat that there's no way Evil Morty could be Rick C-137
Morty because our Rick already has himself
a Morty, and you're right except for one thing
We can prove that our current Morty in the show isn't Rick's original. In close Rickcounters when evil Rick is going through Rick C-137's
Memories we get a flashback
To Rick picking up morty as a baby which causes them to well up with tears not only is it a really touching moment
It's also crucial for piecing together Rick's back
Story based on Jerry crashing into morty's room and "Something Rick and This Way Comes" and also knock next time
You know I mean I'm sitting in here. I'm 14. I got a computer in here
You know we know morty is 14 years old and based on official descriptions of the series on places like Google play and Facebook
We see that Rick has been "missing for nearly 20 years
before
arriving at his daughters
Doorstep looking to move in," this fact is also confirmed in the show when Beth says that she "I used to have to
Draw into family photos with a crayon." Thus the current Morty cannot be Rick's original morty Rick's been gone for over 20 years
But morty's only 14 meaning that rick would have been around when morty was a baby
Now obviously none of that math proves that evil morty is the morty that we see in that memory
But there are some other clues sprinkled throughout the episode that strongly suggests a connection
Let's listen to a bit of what evil rick has to say about Rick's relationship with morty
"We both know that if there's any truth in the universe it's that Rick don't care about mortys." now
well
They might initially seem irrelevant remember that everything evil rick says in the episode is coming from
Evil morty since rick is just a robot controlled by the eye patch with that new understanding
It's obvious that these are words coming from a morty who is fed up with Rick one who resents rick for the mistreatment
He's undergone resentment that probably comes from being experimented on, tortured, maybe even abandoned.
Let's write those down one at a time evil
Morty is obviously
cybernetically enhanced
Since we see at the end of the episode that is eyepatch connects to some wires behind his eye. And we have proof that Rick C-137
Isn't shy about mechanizing his morty. in the season 2 episode the rake's must be crazy
Rick lets us onto a little secret about an enhancement that he gave to morty
Morty:"a long time ago
I implanted you with a subdermal chip that could call upon Dormant nanobots in your bloodstream
To restructure your anatomy and turn you into a car." Morty: "Oh my god!" and at the end of the episode we get proof that he's not
bluffing
(Car Noises)
We also know that evil Morty is aware of how Ricks camouflaged their brainwaves by hanging out with morty
"See, when a rick is with the morty the genius waves get canceled out by the
morty waves
How can we be sure that evil morty knows this? because evil morty sets up a Matrix of kidnapped and tortured
Mortys for his fake rank all to make it seem like the robot Rick under his control was a true Rick committing these crimes
and of course Rick
C-137 was
Surprisingly familiar with this concept "You get a whole Matrix of morty's and put him in agonizing pain
That creates a pattern that can even hide from other Ricks. I fiddled with
the Concepts like this once.
On paper morty on paper." he concludes with oddly specific
Detail that "I mean you can accomplish the same result with like 5 mortys and a jumper cable.
Which I also wouldn't do!" sure you wouldn't rick so you say
But take another look at the visuals we get From Rick  C-137's memories
and we get ourselves the remarkably quick peek at a morty with wires hooked up to his hand getting delivered an
Electric shock. we know that he did perform this experiment on our morty our
M orty certainly would have remembered it meaning that the most likely test subject of that experiment is Rick's first morty
Evil
morty
after all how would he have known that putting morty's in pain would camouflage his brainwaves if he hadn't heard it from a rick the
Cherry on top of all of this is that it sounds an awful
Lot like Rick has had experience with an overconfident
Smart morty before then went on to betray him at the end of the episode when morty's looking for some gratitude from rick for saving
his life
Rick is fast to shut him down by saying a cocky morty can lead to some big problems can be a real bad thing for
Everybody and deflecting any further commentary by telling morty he'd explain it to it when he's older
And an oddly specific detail for rick to just toss out there
Which makes it seem like he's hinting at the fate of his first morty
But all of these things together and what we have a rick who had a party on which he did
Experiments, including cybernetic enhancements and brainwave masking tests and an evil more tea with no rick of his own who has cybernetic enhancements
knowledge of the Rick Brainwave cloaking and an intense hatred
For all of Rick kind seems like a match made in heaven. There is no
God summer Gotta Rip that band-aid off now
You'll thank me later
But here's the kicker
In close Rick counters Rick C-137 s portal gun shows that he's been to all the dimensions where evil morty has killed a rick
He claims
He was being framed and that his portal gun was tampered with
Remotely either way it proves
He has a relationship with Evil morty if he actually was going to the crime scenes it means he's been following the comings and goings
of evil morty for a while now if his portal gun was
Tampered with by Evil morty Why why would Evil Morty kill all the other Rick's but then spare Rick C-137
Why would his goal be to frame that one particular Rick because evil morty the original morty knows that the biggest?
humiliation for the richest of all Rick's would be for Rick to be punished by himself the
Council of Ricks Rick's he considers to be lesser versions of himself
It's the ultimate revenge for a morty with an axe to grind
I'm the rick and so were the rest of you before you form that stupid alliance you wanted to be safe from the government
So you became a stupid government that makes every rick hear less rick than me if you like that mind-blowing revelation
well
Then make sure you hammer morty that
Subscribe button if you don't subscribe to the film theorists within the next 30 seconds and I guarantee that this timeline is going to divide
Thanks to your uncertainty you only have yourself to thank what happened
Maybe rick was trying to create a super morty one just as smart or smarter than himself to help him take down the galactic federation
Without the council of Rick's getting in the way
He enhances this morty mentally in Robotic. Lee
But then bails when he senses that morty is getting too strong or too cruel or too independent he finds the Mortiest Morty
He can to disguise his brain waves and starts over in a new dimension
C-137 that hasn't had a rick in decades
So he can start again from scratch this of course begs the question will evil morty get his revenge
You didn't do it. Ahhh... There you go.. There's the timeline split you didn't subscribe.. Thanks a lot guys...
Now we have to deal with two absurd timeline I mean unless you subscribe!
Which is probably a good idea anyway, because a season 3 of Rick and Morty coming there's gona be a lot more theory in your way.
Oh my gosh. Thank you. I was getting awkward in here
I'm glad that I was able to cure your uncertainty now. We can continue with the episode no more
Uncertain time line Splits will evil more do you get his revenge? There are already some clues that point to yes?
But this time the revenge isn't going to come directly from Evil morty plot twist
It's going to come from our morty because Evil morty's plot all along wasn't necessarily to kill all the Rick's himself
There's no way he ever could know it was to turn all the morty's against all the Rick's I mean think about it
Why would evil morty use a robot rick in the first place if his only goal is to assassinate?
Rick nothing about his plot to assassinate Rick's required anything nearly as elaborate as an eyepatch controlled atomic on it
Could have just gone from dimension to dimension
Using the element of surprise to kill Rick's and still hack Rick C-137 s portal gun to frame him for the murder
It's not like any of the killings were caught on tape
No by creating a fake rick that he used to kidnap and torture
those Morty's, Evil morty is able to indoctrinate an entire army to fight his cause for him and again what a
dramatically perfect way to
Overthrow a Rick: by getting his morty to turn on him.  Evil Morty further fans those flames when the Morty's break out and attack robot
Rick. "Do your worst you little bastards! Kill me! Do it! Doooo I-I-ITT!"
Remember those words have to be coming directly from Evil Morty. Sounds an awful
Lot like he's encouraging Morty aggression toward Rick's. Looks like you stole a trick or two for Emperor Palpatine.
"Do it."
But would other non-evil Morty's really turn on their Rick's in these ways? They already have. In the Rick and Morty comics--
Yes there really are comics of Rick and Morty--
So if you still need more of a fix inject those puppies into your eye holes! Just...
watch out for the eye hole man... Issues number seven, nine, and ten, feature a story Arc in which Morty is
Transported to a world without
Rick's and seeing the differences between this world and the world his previous Rick had destroyed this Morty vowed to rid the multiverse of
All Rick's. We see that resentment bleed over into the main Morty in the comics which I should mention is Morty from Dimension
C132, a similar dimension to C-137, but still one distinct from it as he sees that in a world without rick he becomes
intelligent and powerful:
Concluding that rick is actually holding him back from reaching his full potential! And as for our Morty, Earth Morty,
We're seeing the same thing start to boil over in the show. Let's revisit that scene when Evil Rick, saying Evil Morty's words,
confronts Rick C-137 with how to treat Morty's:  "We both know that if there's any truth in the universe, it's that Rick's don't care about
Morty(s)." Now compare that with the words delivered by our Morty in the season three premiere
When he's spittin' some hard truths to Summer about Rick. "He bailed on mom when she was a kid. H-he bailed on tiny planet! And in
case I never made this clear to you, Summer, he bailed on you! He left you to rot in a world that he ruined! Because
he doesn't care! Because nobody's special to him Summer!" Sound familiar?
And if you think that's all talk don't forget that if Rick had given morty a real gun near the end of that episode
Morty would have shot Rick right in the head. Because at this point
Morty has no illusions. When Morty's back is up against the wall,
he's decided that he's going to choose himself and his family first over rick
whether we get evil Morty back or not, his influence will be there in Earth Morty... just waiting to rear its ugly head.
Who knows! Maybe Earth Morty will one day reveal himself to be the real identity of evil Morty?
But that's just speculation. In the meantime
I'll just let rick himself foreshadow it. "Oh it gets darker, Morty. Welcome to the darkest year of our adventures."
But hey hold on a minute
I think most of us watching this channel can agree that Rick and morty being back is like the best thing to happen to TV
since like the last season of Rick and morty
Seriously when the audience of this channel gets more excited about rick and morty than it does for game of squatching thrones
you know if you got yourself a dedicated audience the only
Problem with that though is that rick and morty is still just a half-hour TV show leaving you with
167 hours and 30 minutes of your week to
Do one stream of parallel universes where every waking moment is full of smart funny thought-provoking
Well-Written animated series well before you start engaging with that oddly specific dangering my friend
I have found that dimension for you
It's called the crunchyroll dimension if you like Rick and morty
Then make sure that you check out one of their newest shows restaurant to another world
I had never seen or heard about this thing until watching it on crunchyroll
But basically instead of going to new dimensions using a portal gun in restaurant to another world you go to new dimensions using a grungy
Restaurant that's no, joke. They actually go through a grungy restaurant where the universe's weirdest Monsters hang out
it's like Rick's portal gun met with the star wars Cantina, but then there's also Dragon and
her
Yeah restaurant to another world. You're going to want to check that one out and not only check it out
but check it out in style click the link in the description to get
Crunchyroll premium for free for 14 days or just use the special link that given exclusively to us theorists crunchyroll.com
Slash Matpat M8 Ep 80 no more pullin anime episodes with incomprehensible selling off the dark quarters of the interwebs
Crunchyroll has episodes one hour after they air in Japan and Super High quality
And practically any device given to us by the gracious generosity of the big giant heads in the sky and most importantly of all them
We're wondering what's watching next when the credits roll after a rick and morty episode because crunchyroll that only has the new stuff
but also must-see anime classics Like Cowboy Bebop
Beautifully written beautifully animated if you haven't seemed Cowboy Bebop and are even remotely
Interested in anime as an art form it is culturally in heritage that you watch that series now even if you don't like anime
It's an incredibly compelling story that you're going to want to watch from beginning to end the bottom line
Is there's tons of content to cover the time after rick and morty ends and the day after and the week after?
And the months when they decide to take a random midseason break what even is that by the way?
What do you need so many great? You don't see film series stopping for a midseason break?
Oh youtube you're unforgiving click the link in the description and fill the void in your entertainment calendar crunchyroll.com
Slash M A T P A T crunchyroll.com
Slash Matpat 14 days of premium for free and hey
that's just a theory a film theory and
Wubba lubba dub dub
I am in constant pain because we don't get midseason break suck it up TV. People. Why do you guys get paid all the bucks?